c'est pour ça que je trouve ça important
d'avoir bon un film qu'on est content
défendre parce qu'en plus ils envoient
du lourd quoi le film franchement mais
kim équipe n'a peut-être c'est vrai gars
ça envoie du lourd
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à la lecture du scénario on se dit qu'on
a entre les mains un truc rares je crois
dans le cinéma français un truc un peu
hybride qui à la fois un souffle de
grands films de spectacles où on sent
que en plus en connaissant le cinéma de
cédric gimenez qui va y avoir une mise
en scène enlevée un rythme incroyable et
en même temps on a des personnages très
fort très dessinée très complémentaires
dont on sait qu on a aussi un film de
personnages et on sait qu'on a un film
qui parle de faits de société et de
dérives de nos sociétés donc on sait
qu'on a du fond aussi quoi on a un film
qui allie le fond et la forme à
merveille ce qui est assez rare ouais on
puisse ya eu beaucoup de travail en plus
en amont les fastes c'était assez
chouette en plus du scénario on a eu un
petit temps de vraiment pour répéter
ensemble pour se connaître pour
travailler autour des scènes que ce soit
avec cédric ou avec françois et gilles
et c'est vrai que tout ce travail en
plus de ce scénario là et de la
personnalité de cédric fait que ouais
comme le dit françois il ya quelque
chose de dense est chouette de trouver
ça puisque c'est assez rare d'avoir un
objet je trouve de deux spectacles et de
divertissement mais qu'il ya aussi une
couche sociétal aussi forte et et qui
raconte notre société et notre temps
c'est ce qui est plaisant avons tous et
de recevoir un beau scénario fait et
puis ensuite quand les personnages sont
bien décrits et sondé psychologie un peu
fouillé et qui disent qu'ils vivent qui
sortent du film de genre en tout cas de
l'habitude qu'on en a des polars avec
film policier que c'était fini les
personnages tout petit peu plus moins
caricaturaux d'habitude aussi évidemment
bien sûr que c'est plaisant webb a
surtout que
on joue trois flics de la bac d'une
brigade est en fait c'est des liens
hyper hyper fort entre ces gars là qui
passe entre 8 et 10 heures dans une même
voiture donc le côté immersif nous on
l'a vécu quoi on on passait aussi tous
les trois avec laurent tanguy le chef
opérateur qui a une petite caméra mais
qui étaient avec nous donc il m'était
vraiment la caméra dans le véhicule et
donc a découlé tout ça pas mal de
moments où c'est l'improvisation dont on
avait parlé en amont on essayait un peu
de mètres de là de la banalité dans
leurs conversations pour les essayer de
donner un peu d'épaisseur aussi à ses
personnages pour pas que ce soit juste
un film c'est l'action qui guident tout
mais s'il ya un peu de les nourrir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
compliqué certainement mais c'est
surtout
obligatoires moi je vois les acteurs de
cinéma magma mission surtout dans ce
type de sujet qui n'a fait redescendre
non jugé avec des personnages
existant entre quand on s'inspire de ses
personnages existants qui sont encore là
donc c'est trop frais pour pouvoir avoir
des conclusions ce serait très mal venu
de ma part voire très près d'un sur deux
de pouvoir en sert uniquement mon
travail c'est de faire des films j'ai
voulu faire un film cela mais évidemment
mon obligation la moindre des choses
c'est d'avoir de la hauteur je trouve
que le fait de surtout de vivre les
choses de vivre ce que traversent nos
personnages surtout très enrichissant
voilà d'avoir des personnages complexes
des personnages qui qui sont pas
justement des stéréotypes et qui effet
eu de frayer leur chemin et d'aller vers
vers ce vers quoi ils tendent
à travers une société comme ça ça me
semble un hyper intéressant à
interpréter je trouve qu'au contraire
c'est
bénéfique d'avoir des personnages avec
toutes ses dimensions là à jouer
[Musique]
mais je crois que c'est le sas et
l'ambition
cinématographique j'attends de cédric et
je pense qu'il l'a prouvé par le passé
il est capable de faire des grandes
fresques avec du souffle et en effet
cédé inspiration sans doute anglo saxon
part en moi mais mais il il aime bien
quand il aime bien quand il y en a quoi
sert il aime bien en mettre et c'est un
kiff clairement j'ai
[Musique]
j'ai adoré le cinéma américain des
années 70 c'est une certitude mais pas
que le cinéma américain aussi le cinéma
français de ces de ces mêmes années
l'ours a ressurgi certainement dans mon
cinéma mais c'est pas une volonté je
suis pas en train de me dire je veux
être dans la veine de ou dans la
continuité 2 ben on fait ce qu'on aime
moi je fais les films que j'ai envie de
voir et donc c'est vrai que certainement
les films qui m'ont marqué
ressemble à ces films des années 70
qu'ils soient américains ou français ça
doit sa reçu rhji je pense consciemment
ou inconsciemment
dans mes films mais ya pas une volonté
de continuité ou d'être l'héritage de
dont je je je je me permettrai pas ça